the chapter breaks are truly takeaways
like this is not they're like red table
takeaways that's why they're in the
little you know red border what you call
them I call them chapter breaks but
they're like they're guidance pages
chapter break they need a title because
more people need to do this because
they're such a takeaway this is not just
your story this is an enhancement and a
guide book for life through what I
imagine is extensive about of money time
hours and Investments that you've pulled
from extraordinary resources and
filtered out for us well that's that was
the whole point it was like yes I'm
telling my story but I wanted everybody
to see themselves within the journey
because we're all on a journey towards
self-worth in some form of fashion all
of us right I think that it is it is a
universal theme that we're all trying to
figure out our value we're all trying to
figure out our lovableness I think
that's the thing that I loved and I hope
this doesn't bury the lead in the book
but the way that you speak of how you
love people MH be who you are feel what
you feel but I still love you yeah you
can love will you can love yourself how
can we love ourselves yeah I think that
one of those next you know stages in
relationships is when you really learn
how to accept yourself fully
you really learn how to accept your
partner fully as well you know and
that's been a journey all in itself and
you learn how to accept everyone else
you know even when you're dealing with
their Shadow right so you just learn how
to embrace the the light of people as
well as the shadow so I I love will as
who he is I've learned to love and
embrace Chris you know as who he is and
myself as well and that's what it's
about we're all here just trying to
figure it out you know I just got this
tattooed and you mention it in the book
I am human that's it if we can just
learn how to accept and embrace our
humanness we can't be human beings and
have a disdain for humanness and
humanness is beautiful and flawed all at
the same time and the moment that we can
just embrace it all and have acceptance
and it doesn't mean accepting means
condoning or not growing or what have
you but just understanding that it's all
a process it's all a process and we're
not here to be perfect and can I
separate you from the man cuz you are
the woman and Absol gotten to know and
whether you're you know in a many
different evolutions of your of your
story right I feel
like maybe your and his
shadow separ separated in a way in this
book whether they stay together forever
or not right you know sounds like you're
staying together for we're staying
together forever perfect okay tried um
we tried great I just I was like I don't
even need to talk about him very much I
want to be with you I want to be with
this human being and you are such a
dynamic human
[Music]
being